[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: Good
afternoon, everyone.
Thank you for being present.
Happy women's day to all
the ladies in the audience.
And it is a pleasure and an
honor being here at Google.
It was always on
the 25th of December
that my late father Rolando used
to recite the exact same story
year in and year out to my elder
brother Giovanni and myself.
It wasn't one of
his own stories.
It didn't stem from
his own experiences.
But it was a story
that was related
to him by a former
mentor of his, Dr. Rossi,
when my father used to work at
the Cyprus embassy in London.
The story was about a former
Undersecretary of Defense
and that former Undersecretary
of Defense was invited,
for the second year running,
at the same conference.
As he took up the podium, he
was holding a styrofoam cup
with coffee in his hand.
And before he started speaking,
he went off script, took a sip,
smiled, turned, looked
at the audience and said,
I want to talk to you
about this styrofoam cup.
Last year, I was the
Undersecretary of Defense.
I flew here business class.
A limousine was waiting
for me at the airport
to drive me to my hotel.
They already checked me in.
The next day, there was
another limousine waiting
to bring me to this venue.
They escorted me
to the green room,
and the green room
is the room where
all speakers meet and prepare
before they take the stage.
And when I asked for
something to drink,
they brought me coffee
in a ceramic cup.
This year, I'm no longer the
Undersecretary of Defense.
I came.
I flew economy class.
I took a taxi from the airport
all the way to my hotel.
I checked myself in
and it took 15 minutes.
The next day, I took another
taxi to come to this venue.
And because I couldn't remember
where the green room was,
I asked them to escort me, and
they gave me mere directions
how to get there.
Then I asked for
something to drink.
And they showed me
the vending machine.
And they said take
a styrofoam cup,
and serve yourself
whatever you like.
He turns, looks at
the audience and says,
we all deserve a styrofoam cup.
The ceramic cup was
never meant for us.
It was meant for the position
that I was holding at the time.
So as you gain fame, as you
gain fortune, positions,
or possessions, people
will open up doors for you.
They will refer to
you as sir and madam.
They will bring gifts.
And when you ask for
something to drink,
they will bring your coffee
or your tea in a ceramic cup.
But because time
doesn't stand still,
we all deserve a styrofoam cup.
And as the former
Undersecretary of Defense
found out the hard way, we, too,
should be alerted to the fact
and to the possibility
that we might not
be our current position
or our possessions.
Who we really are, as
today's title suggests,
which is Finding
Your Inner Compass,
is that internal compass,
when you strip away
positions or possessions
that will guide you
through challenging and
difficult moments in business
and in life.
Today, my dear friends, I will
relay five personal stories.
And each story carries
a valuable lesson.
That's the lessons that power
my internal compass and helped
me navigate through
the professional
and the personal world.
I hope that by the
end of this speech,
these same stories and
the underlying messages
from these stories will help
power your internal compass
and help you navigate
better in your life.
So they make the road
more smooth in order
to reach for that elusive
word, which is called success.
Three disclaimers to make--
each and every lesson
starts with the letter H,
as you will see from each story.
Second disclaimer--
there are no PowerPoints.
Unlike 95% of my
keynote speaking,
there are no PowerPoints.
Because I do not
believe that a slide
can depict internal
compasses and values, as well
as a vivid story which
carries an underlying message.
And disclaimer number three--
the third story, which
happened 13 years ago in 2006,
I've never ever before
said this story in front
of a professional audience.
I only once
mentioned this story,
and that was on the
9th of October 2018
as I was lecturing at University
College London in front
of 300 students.
So let's begin.
And let me take
you back to 1997.
That was the year that
I completed my studies
in the United Kingdom.
I'd done my BA and
my master's degree.
And like any good Cypriot boy
who has a flourishing business,
I went back to the
island, back to Cyprus
to work for the family business.
All newcomers at
our family business,
which was called Virardi--
it's still called Virardi,
we deal with catering
equipment and tabletop supplies
for the HoReCa industry, the
HoReCa industry is hotels,
restaurants, and
catering institutions--
had to go through
an induction course.
And that induction
course started
from my late father's office.
And I, too, had to go
through the same procedure.
That was what I
called my PhD degree.
Only it didn't last five years.
It lasted five minutes.
My father gave me two
valuable pieces of advice.
For the first piece of advice,
my father took a pencil.
And he took a sharpener.
And he said, Michael,
I've sharpened your edge.
I paid your [INAUDIBLE] and
I paid for your tuition.
But if you leave a pencil
standing on its own,
it will fall.
Go out there, son,
and find the hand
that will keep you standing.
The hand that will
keep you standing
was an analogy for the
mentors in my life,
for the trusted
advisors, the likes
of your former colleague
[INAUDIBLE] was escorting me
here, all the mistakes
that I've done in my life
and all the failures
that I've encountered.
Because as the saying
goes, when you lose,
don't lose the lesson.
And I owe a very big thank
you to all the people
who turned me down and all those
who believed in me to hire me.
And as I was making my way
out of my father's office,
he gave me the second
piece of advice.
He said, son, I see
something in you.
My feeling is that you will do
well in life 10, 15 years down
the road.
And when you do well, when you
gain positions and possessions,
if, for any reason
you think that there
is one person that you don't
need them because you've either
outgrown them or getting
a better position,
that's the day--
and as an inexperienced
professional, young
professional, I rushed
to fill in the sentence--
and I said, that's the
day that I made it, Dad?
He said no.
That's the day that
you lost it all, son.
So the first H in our first
story, my dear friends,
is H for being humble.
Understanding that as you
rise up the hierarchy ladder,
as you taste success,
always remain humble,
because we are not our
current successors.
We are not our trophies.
We are not our positions
or our possessions.
Which leads me to the second
story that happened in 1998.
I was one year into
the family business.
And lo and behold, the company
that my dad told me to take
care of, which was Carlisle
Food Service Products--
it's the tumblers where you
have your juice here at Google,
Carlisle Food Service Products--
we won the first European award.
So the Americans told us to
fly all the way to Charlotte,
together with my brother,
all expenses paid,
to get our award.
And we were lucky,
because there were
seven days of celebrations.
And on the last day,
Jeffrey Gitomer,
one of the best sales
consultants in the United
States, came to speak to us.
For all those who know me,
I cannot stand still for 10
minutes.
I stayed riveted on my chair
for six consecutive hours.
As soon as Jeffrey
Gitomer finished his talk,
I ran up to him and I said,
Mr. Gitomer, congratulations.
How can I become like you, sir?
And he turned, looked at
me, and said, it's easy
and it's difficult.
And as a Cypriot, I
said, what's easy?
[LAUGHTER]
He said study on
your chosen topic,
whichever topic that is,
for two hours every day,
except weekends.
In five years, you will be
recognized in your country--
in 10 years, worldwide.
I said, sir, I'll start today.
I bought his books.
At the time, he had only
two books, "The Sales Bible"
and "Customer
Satisfaction is Worthless,
Customer Loyalty is Priceless."
I even bought his cassettes--
not DVDs, not CDs, not USBs,
but cassettes.
And I was listening to
Jeffrey Gitomer's cassettes
in my car, which was sales
messages coming out, driving
from one town of
Cyprus to the next,
promoting Carlisle Food
Service Products and all
the other products
that we had at Virardi.
And I was weeping in my car,
listening to the messages.
And I have a feeling
that people looking
from the outside thought that
I was going to a funeral.
[LAUGHTER]
I still remember my favorite
tape, my favorite cassette.
It was "101.5
Rules for Success."
Let me tell you my
favorite rule for success.
It was the 101.5.
You're given a bucket of
water and a bucket of cement.
You can either build
a stepping stone
toward success or
a stumbling block.
The choice is yours.
And he was right.
Even the great author
Malcolm Gladwell in his book
"Outliers", he said
the exact same thing.
He popularized a
notion that wasn't his,
but it was the 10,000 hours.
Malcolm Gladwell said that if
you want to achieve something,
you need to put those
10,000 hours in.
Even the Beatles were unknown
for seven consecutive years
as they played music in what
was eastern Germany at the time.
And it was after they hit
that mark, the 10,000 hour
mark, that people started
to recognize them.
Even great criminals,
as it says in the book,
need 10,000 hours to
perfect their craft.
So my dear friends, the
second H is H for hard work.
I know you work at a
technology company.
And I know that intelligent
work is also important.
But hard work takes precedence
over intelligent work.
I guess what I'm
saying to you is,
sacrifice something today so
you can gain something better
tomorrow.
Which leads us to
the third story,
which I've never
before said in front
of a professional audience.
You can cut the camera now.
I'm joking.
2006, as a good Cypriot boy
who was working at the family
business, getting a bit older--
by the way, I am 46, even
though I look 45, just
for your information--
it was time to get married.
700,000 inhabitants on
the island of Cyprus.
We invited 4,000 to the wedding.
And it was almost 1%.
And the night
before the wedding,
I found out that my
wife was cheating on me.
Yes.
I know, you say such
a good looking guy,
and she's cheating on you.
Can you believe that?
I had the same feeling.
[LAUGHTER]
So what did I do?
I had to think for a while.
And then I called
everything off.
My mother was crying.
My late grandmother
was hysterical.
What will happen
to the family name?
What will happen to our image?
What will happen to your image?
What will happen to my life?
I told them.
The only person who hasn't
spoken, like always,
and waited and
waited, was my dad.
So he comes up to me,
and he says Michael,
let's go to the front veranda.
The front veranda
in my parents' home
was where the bad
news were delivered.
The back veranda was where
the good news were delivered.
So I go to the front veranda.
He puts his hand
on my shoulders.
And he says, son.
You have guts.
Actually, the word
he used wasn't guts.
[LAUGHTER]
But for this speech
at Google, it's guts.
When I die, he continued
on, I'm very happy.
And I will die
peacefully knowing
that I can leave the company
to your brother Giovanni, who
has the wisdom and the
patience, and also to you, son,
who has guts.
So my dear friends, the
third H is H for honesty.
And I'm not talking about
honesty from the other person.
Because you cannot control that.
It's being honest
with yourselves.
To take the hard decisions,
even if it pains you at the time
that you're taking
those decisions.
And we move on to
the fourth story.
One year after not proceeding
with the wedding, 2007,
now I had to find the guts to
go tell my dad that I wanted
to leave the company and
pursue what you see me
now doing, giving keynotes,
training, development,
and consulting.
I go up to my dad.
I explain what I wanted to do.
He says, son, let's go
to the front veranda.
We go to the front veranda.
He said Michael,
you can go your way.
I'm sure you will succeed.
But if you leave,
Virardi will close down.
He bought himself 1,100 days.
I stayed at the family business
for another three years.
And when the time
passed, I went back.
My father was a true gentleman.
He said son, you
will do very well.
But I would like to
give you some advice.
Go your own way, but I would
like to give you some advice.
This is where the
fourth H comes in.
Always be helpful.
Deliver value first
or deliver value
without expecting
anything in return.
And he gave me two
pieces of advice
that I will never forget.
The first piece of advice was
that when you meet prospects
and they ask you
to give quotations,
never merely write a quotation.
Write a self-help book.
Give them so much value that
they can see their vision.
Give them so much
material and value
so they can bring it to life.
If they decide to come with you,
your prize will seem minute.
If they opt to go
with your competitors,
at least you have
built a stepping stone
towards their success.
And my father was right.
And I still do it
up until today.
Even recently when a
company from New York
contacted me to do a
culture enhancement project,
which involved
strengthening the team,
and it had a 360
degree evaluation
which means that those
managers were evaluated
by the top management, by their
peers, by their subordinates,
and by customers--
I didn't just write a quotation.
I even sent a five page PDF with
all the questions, everything
that I was intending to ask.
And if I don't get
the job, I still
know that I added a
value to that company.
And if I do get the
job, they can come back
and alter some
questions, change some,
and even give me some feedback.
What my father was telling
me is be a trusted advisor,
not a salesperson.
And I guess what
I'm telling you is
transform your thinking from
what can I get from you to
how can I serve you.
And the second piece of
advice he gave me that day
was that, Michael, you
will never be the smartest
person in the room.
And my dad had foresight.
Even though he
died 19 months ago,
he never knew I was
coming to Google.
So this guy had foresight.
And it's true, my dear friends.
Even if you are one in a
million, in a 7 billion
population, there are another
7,000 people exactly like you.
Why should they hire you?
Recently I was at
Singularity University.
I took a course there.
And they have the
same philosophy.
They were telling us that
engineers, the brightest
minds, scientists, were
trying to fold protein three
dimensionally.
And they were trying
for 15 years non-stop,
and they never managed it.
They opened up.
They open sourced it.
And in 10 days only, a wife
from the Midwest folded protein.
So the experts are
the nonexperts.
The experts sometimes are
outside your organization.
And it is not a coincidence
that in the book
of how Google works, it says
on page 175, default to open.
So if you cannot be the
smartest person in the room,
you can be something else.
In my case, I opted
to be the promptest.
And I have a rule.
If you go into my
website, you will
see that I reply back to my
messages with the rule 7, 7, 7.
I reply back in 7 seconds,
if I'm not doing anything.
I reply immediately.
In seven minutes, if
I'm doing something,
I want to finish
it and then reply.
Or in seven hours, which is
the duration of a workshop.
I finish the workshop
and then I reply back.
I'm not telling you to do
that within this framework.
But expand it, if you like, to
14, 14, 14, or 21 seconds, 21
minutes, or 21 hours.
But refrain from staying
at the 24 hour rule, which
was invented when there were
telephones plugged on the wall
and not smart devices.
And when they were--
at that time, people
were more backward.
So my dear friends, the
fourth H is to be helpful.
Which leads us to the fifth and
final H. And for this story,
I need to take you to 9/11/2011.
That was the day that
I married the woman
of my dreams, the lady that
puts a smile on a daily face--
on a [INAUDIBLE] on my face--
and that's Christine.
And on the 28th of January
2013, she delivered the greatest
present in our lives, and that's
our six-year-old Rolando, who
wanted to accompany
me on this trip
to meet the people behind
his favorite platform
and that is YouTube,
because thanks to you,
he observes-- he
meticulously observes
Cristiano Ronaldo's soccer
moves on a daily-- sorry--
hourly basis.
So when we were going to
get married with Christine,
Christine went to
her grandfather,
who passed away recently, who
was married to his childhood
sweetheart for 68 years.
And she asked for advice
for a happy marriage.
And her grandfather was very
happy to give that advice.
I don't know.
Maybe he was worried
that I would walk away
from this wedding, as well.
And he said to her,
Christine, do you
know what's the secret to a
happy and a long-term wedding?
And Christine said, what's
the secret, Grandfather?
He said give 100% to your spouse
and expect zero in return.
If your husband to be gives
100% and expects zero in return,
then you increase your chances
of having a happy wedding.
Think about it, my friends.
It also applies to
all the other Hs.
Give 100% to your marriage
or to your relationships,
and expect zero in return.
Give 100% to hard work
and intelligence work.
Be 100% honest, first and
foremost, with yourselves.
Even if it pains you at the time
you take the decision, take it.
If you're wrong, admit
it and apologize.
Be 100% helpful by offering
value to others first.
And be 100% humble, not because
you will need someone further
down the line in your
career, but because it
is the right thing to do.
So if you're wondering by
now, what's the fifth H?
The fifth H is H for heart.
Open your heart
and pour your heart
in everything and
anything that you do,
because it's only in this
way that you can move away
from positions and possessions,
and you move closer
to your true North.
And by true North, I mean
that internal compass
that is helping you to
navigate through life.
After all, my dear
friends, it is that compass
that represents who you are as
human beings at your deepest
level.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for being here today with us.
Personally the talk
talked to my heart.
And I think you
represented a few
of the values we
have in the company,
like put the user first,
be humble, take risks.
So it's nice remembering
again and again.
I have a few questions.
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: OK.
Ask one, then.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: My first
question is about mentors.
Do you want to tell
us who were a few
of your mentors along the way?
And my question is, how
do you find mentors?
Is it something that comes in
your life or you seek for them?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI:
Excellent question--
I had many mentors.
And mentors do not have age.
If I'm going to be giving
a speech on technology,
I rush to find younger
people, older people.
It depends-- the people
who are well-versed.
My father was my
first ever mentor.
I had mentors from my university
days, my college professors.
I even meet people on the road,
which I keep in touch, always.
But you cannot find a mentor
if you are not ready to receive
a mentor in your life
and to receive advice.
And I hope I have answered
your question in this way.
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
And can I ask it seems like the
father role model in your life,
it really played
an important role.
Have you kept, I
don't know, his wisdom
in one sentence maybe
or something you want
to share with us about this?
It seems like a very
precious relationship.
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: It was a
very precious relationship.
My father died on the
22nd of August 2017.
And at that time
that he died, he
was wearing his
Virardi T-shirt which
said customer service first.
So my father always
believed that you
should serve your customer.
And that customer is also
the internal customer.
And the way you treat
your internal customers
is the way that your
internal customers will
serve your external customers.
So at the end of
the day, my father
wasn't focused on the
price of the products.
He wasn't focused so
much on the quality,
even though he
believed in quality,
that's why we imported
a lot of German things.
But he believed in people.
And he believed
in helping people.
Give first, and then
you will receive.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
thank you very
much for this inspiring speech.
In your second story,
you were talking
about the advice
you got to follow,
to practice two hours
of a certain topic
to become very good at it.
And you immediately said,
OK, I'm going to start today.
I know exactly
what this topic is.
Now in my situation,
I'm 30 years old now--
or 29, actually.
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI:
Like me, 46, 45.
AUDIENCE: Exactly--
I don't know yet
which is the precise topic that
I want to focus on that drives
me for the next 15 years.
And I also believe that this is
kind of a generational thing.
So what advice
would you give to us
to find this topic where you
have your passion and the topic
that follows you and
that basically drives you
over the next 10 to 15 years?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: I was 29--
that's a great
question, by the way.
I was 29 years old when
I found my passion, when
I saw Jeffrey Gitomer on stage.
I was mesmerized.
I went up to him
and I asked him.
Before that, I was working
for the family business.
And even though I was
enjoying it very much,
I felt it like you
are feeling it now.
That it might be this
or something else.
What I will say to you is,
whatever you're doing now,
give it your best.
As Muhammad Ali once said, if
you are sweeping the floors,
sweep it to the best
of your abilities.
Give it your best, because
somebody is watching.
My late father always
told me to keep
a note for everyone I meet.
What did I like, what I
didn't like, because even--
I'm not saying
about your manager--
but even if your manager
doesn't appreciate what you do,
which is not the case,
but I'm just saying it--
so why are you laughing, guys?
Somebody else is watching.
And whilst you're
doing what you are
doing to the best
of your abilities,
an opportunity will
knock the door.
So be conscientious,
do what you do,
continue being knowledgeable.
Put in those hours in
what you're doing now.
But you have to be
honest with yourselves.
If this doesn't
inspire you, you need
to take the painful decision
and do something else.
And I'm not only talking
about relationships.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask-- you mentioned
that you had kind of understood
three years before you
left the company that you
wanted to change career paths.
So how did you find the
courage to actually leave
after three years and just
go off and do your own thing?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI:
If there scared
means that I had the
courage, yes, then I
believed I was preparing
myself for 10 years
to find the courage to
go and do what I'm doing.
And from the day that I
decided to go on my own,
I had to believe in
myself first and foremost.
I took my father's
advice on board.
And I was adamant.
Even though-- and
I will tell you--
when I went for my first gig
and they asked me, Michael,
how much do you
charge for a speech?
At that time, at that time,
it was 1,500 Cyprus pounds.
And the guy said excuse me,
1,500 pounds for a one hour
speech.
Do you know how much your
competitors are charging?
And he told me two names which
had 30 years of experience
and they were
charging 500 pounds.
Why should I pay
you 1,500 pounds?
And you don't even
have experience.
And I said, sir, I was
preparing for 10 years.
And if you don't like it, I
will give you your money back.
And he threw me
out of the office.
[LAUGHTER]
But the next year, somebody
else believed in me.
I kept the 1,500 ceiling
and they gave me a chance.
It went on to YouTube,
which is owned,
I think you know which
company, by Google.
And thanks to Google,
I commanded my pricing.
And thanks to the
performance on stage--
because my father told me, if
you are going on your own son,
don't put your prices low.
Because if you are very
good at what you do,
it will never go up high.
Or it will take 10
years to go up here.
Put your prices high.
Deliver more value
than expected.
You'll get a lot of rejections.
But you will get a
chance, eventually.
And if you are wondering
where will you find the money,
you can do two
jobs until you find
the money to go for your dream.
AUDIENCE: So you're talking
about really believing
in yourself and continuing
on, as well training yourself
and learning and
educating yourself.
And then going for it?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: Yes.
But I'm a little bit against
the secret and its philosophy
that think about
it, it will come.
Think about-- no,
work and it will come.
Put in those hours
and it will come.
And always keep
your bridges open.
My late father used to tell me
always send a Christmas card.
At that time, they were
sending Christmas card.
But always send
a Christmas card.
Always connect with the people
that you meet on the road.
Because your network will
determine your net worth
at the end of the day,
not only your abilities.
AUDIENCE: And I have one
more question, if that's OK?
You spoke about the
true North of yourself.
So if you do not mind, speaking
to us about that a bit more.
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: I will
speak about my true North.
Beyond possessions,
beyond positions,
I agree with my father
that you need to be humble.
Because what else
is there to be?
And I find my true
North when I hug my son,
or when I'm with my wife.
And I think what powers
everything is the word trust.
If you trust people
who are in your life,
you have less tension
and more trust
to go forward and do
what you need to do.
You even have allies
within your company,
within your relationship,
inside your flat,
or inside your house.
You need allies, because no
man or woman is an island.
You cannot do it alone.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I have one more question.
How do we learn and
navigate around failures?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: I also
said before that when you lose,
don't lose the lesson.
A failure is a
chance to understand.
For me, when I used to work at
the Virardi family business,
I always asked, where
did you find us?
For you guys, you know
where did they find you.
It's called Google
AdWords and the rest.
But I used to ask, and
when I fail at something,
which what is failure?
If you stand up,
you're still standing.
You need to ask what went
wrong, contemplate, think,
look at your offer again.
Talk to people, even to the
people who consider you,
in inverted commas, a failure.
So the best way is asking.
Like great
contingency is placing
the questions, more questions.
Questions are very important.
You judge a man or
a woman or a person
by the quality of
their questions,
not by the quality
of their answers.
That's how you
deal with failure--
with lots of questions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very
much for the speech.
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I was focusing on the
part, your rule of the 7, 7, 7,
and then also the 10,000
hours that you put in.
And I mean, you were
working full time
for the family business.
On top of that, you
put in 10,000 hours.
And now you're traveling around
the world giving speeches,
and you still reply
[INAUDIBLE] 7, 7, 7.
How do you do that?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: You can
test it tonight if you like.
Yes?
I fly Emirates.
There is Wi-Fi connection
if I'm going transatlantic.
Yes, I do it because
if you're prompt,
people attribute
more things to you.
That you are reliable.
That you are dependable.
That you are the one
they should work with.
And it's also a
differentiator on its own.
Marilyn asked me, how do
you deal with failures?
I also should turn the
question on its head.
How do you deal with success?
I ask, why did the
American [INAUDIBLE],,
why did Microsoft hire me?
I asked them.
And you know what's the answer
I get most of the times?
It's not because
you are the best.
Because I said earlier, if
you are one in a million
in a 7 billion population,
there are another 7,000 people
like you which they're
very good and they
may have a lower price.
90% told me because you
are prompt, Michael.
Because you are reliable.
Because we were in a hurry
to set it up, and I knew
I could count on you.
There are other
things, of course.
You shouldn't stand up here
and talk about theories
that you don't believe in.
You shouldn't talk about
other people's stories
except if that's an example
that you want to aim for,
to be truthful and the rest.
So I do it because
it's also in my favor,
because most people won't do it.
Imagine if somebody
walks into your house
and you don't greet them
because you're busy.
It's impolite.
Somebody is walking into
your electronic house,
and they're knocking the door.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much
for the speech, Mr. Virardi.
How would you define success?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI:
Excellent question--
that's why I use the
word elusive for success.
It cannot be defined.
And it cannot be so broad
to include all of us.
Success is a different thing
for every different person.
If you ask me what success--
success is Christine
and Rolando.
Success, for me, is
to live by the values
that my father instilled in
me, and my mother, of course.
Success is to wake
up in the morning
and be happy doing what you're
doing, love what you're doing.
And if you're not happy with
it, I'm not saying quit.
But find a way to
be happy doing it.
And be honest enough
if you are not.
If it's after six years,
it really pains you?
Find the strength to move on.
That's success.
Because some people tell me,
Michael, you are a freelancer.
Sometimes you might
not work as hard.
No.
I work hard to see
a vision and to go
after that vision
with no guarantees.
So for me that was success.
For you it might
be something else.
But it's elusive.
As they say in
theater, you are as
good as your last performance.
And in my job, you are as good
as your last speech or training
session.
AUDIENCE: I want to
talk a little bit
about your public
speaking career
and acknowledge that about half
the people in the Google Dublin
office don't have English
as their first language.
So it's a challenge to
speak, but even more so
when English is not
your first language.
So can you tell us a little
bit about how you ramped up
your communication skills?
How do you practice?
What are your tips?
MICHAEL R. VIRARDI: Excellent.
Very good.
Because we are also addressing
this on the online program
that is coming out.
There was once a
great football player
by the name of
Milenko Spoljaric.
He used to play for my
team in Cyprus, Apollon.
Milenko was a very talented
player, extremely talented.
He never played in Europe.
He never played
in the big league
because he was very slow.
And he gave me a
piece of advice.
If you're a slow player,
pass the ball faster.
The ball travels much
faster than if you dribble.
So if you are not
a native speaker,
it's not the fancy words.
Keep it short, keep it simple,
and practice, practice,
practice, practice.
Perfect practice makes perfect.
So try it again.
And keep it simple.
Even with my mentees-- when
they come for coaching sessions
one on one, even if that
is-- even if they're
in their native
language is English,
I always tell them,
keep it short.
Keep it simple.
They gave me 45 minutes,
one hour to speak,
I spoke 30 minutes.
You shouldn't be
keeping it too long.
If the people get the gist
of what you want to say,
it's not the fancy words.
And think about it, which
is your favorite politician?
My feeling is it's not someone
who uses language that you
cannot resonate
with or understand.
But it's someone who
speaks to your heart.
Keep it short.
Keep it simple.
And practice.
Thank you very much.
It was a pleasure and an honor.
[APPLAUSE]